si j'avais accouché avant le tournage je
n'aurais pas joué comme ça c'est fou
donc en fait j'étais assez silencieux
c'est à dire que j'étais là en mode moi
je pensais que j'avais fériés souffre
comme dans tous les films un truc asie
respire respire que dalle j'étais là
derrière comme ça un peu en muet et
j'étais juste un support et quand la ma
fille aînée ce qui est fou en fait
l'émotion j'ai compris qu'elle venait en
fait pas d'eux est venu avait amené de
la surprise que j'avais à découvrir la
tête que j'avais moins imaginer dans le
ventre en disant que comme ça comme si
est en fait tu j'étais ému de la
surprise de 2,2 de découvrir ma fille
non mais en vrai est membre embrasser
extraordinaire et même quand on regarde
des images moi je peux être ému pourtant
je suis pas qq1 j'ai pas facile mais si
je vois à temps je l'aurais au film turc
non je n'ai pas vu je n'ai pas vu le
coup c'est moi qui plus est alors que
j'ai rien contre les turcs mais il se
trouve que je n'ai pas vu et les images
d'accouchement moi ça me fait chialer
tout le temps bon alors voilà parce que
c'est promis juré
oui oui oui et moi j'ai été tenté de
regarder un peu d'air le truc parce que
à un moment donné il m'a dit mettez
votre main apprenez le voulait prendre
le bébé et j'ai fait qu'un set j'ai et
je me suis retenu je crois que j'ai bien
fait je sais pas j'ai jamais été de
l'autre côté
[Musique]
on n'a pas d'enfant sans main attention
maryse méprise les nuits sans sommeil
franchement c'est surtout quand tu
bosses en même temps il ya un il ya ces
sénateurs en fout en fait ça ça te rend
fou et puis et puis non absolument pas
préparés tout le c'est d'une certaine
manière parce que l'on te préviens mes
mais quand tu le vis c'est waouh c'est
un tsunami donc mais t'as pas le choix
et puis avant que la petite phase et
nuit véritablement on sait pas le temps
on sait pas quand elle va faire ses
nuits véritablement de la distance
peut-être fait qu'on leur raconte
l'histoire non j'ai merdé beaucoup de
trucs avec mes enfants ils tiennent très
mal à table c'est des poubelles et sont
extrêmement grossier il est aussi
vulgaire que jean marie bigard a besoin
mais sur brut mais non mais par contre
je n'ai pas eu de problèmes de sommeil
avec les enfants ça arrive aussi les
enfants qui font leurs lumières deux
mois trois mois et même je dirais même
que j'ai le souvenir du le biberon de 3
heures du mat
encore une fois je donner le biberon
c'est un souvenir à ses gars parce que
la ville est arrêtée tout on a
l'impression d'être seuls au monde avec
son enfant voilà c'est passé pas c'est
pas des mauvais souvenirs et en fait cet
amour immédiat oui il est là
moi par exemple je peux parler que de
mon cas de fait le choix fois père basse
assez graduel
voilà c'est dire qu'au début ça s'est
tellement surréaliste en fait au final
d'apparaître tapas et et a pas eu
d'enfant pendant toute ta vie d'un coup
d'un enfant c'est un peu surréaliste tu
sais que c'est le tien je sais que cette
api mais il n'ya pas encore la connexion
mehdi et moi je vois aujourd'hui elle un
an et demi ma fille je suis comme un fou
d'elle j'ai jamais autant aimé ma fille
que maintenant parce que le lien il se
fait pas comme ça en fait voilà et sans
nous on ne dit pas ça dans les films on
nous dit linverse mais surtout arrêtez
d'écouter les conseils qui sont
forcément mortifère des autres parents
fatigués ou dépressifs et qui se feront
une joie de vous raconter à quel point
c'est horrible
c'est super il suffit de faire à sa
manière on n'est pas plus débile que
doit c'est clair voilà la raison parce
que moi on m'a donné 1700 conseil au
final j'ai tenté de cantates arrive en
temps réel tu fais à ta sauce et a pas
le choix en fait voilà c'est comme ça on
apprend ça c'est totalement empirique et
tu as j'étais content de le placer
semaine et on attend on apprend jour
après jour à agir et le truc mais prend
un tsunami quand même et c'est comme ça
et c'est la vie ça fait partie du job